this Miller hamdulillah Salaam alaikum
peace be with you strava courtesy ciao
vostra on I bully pozdrav jaan i owed
mere assalamo alaikum Nicki a mere
stubborn peace be with you now people
are like what is this guy talking about
but for the people from the Balkans the
people who are doesn't matter if you're
a Serb or Albanian or Bosnian these are
nationalities and they shouldn't split
us apart the way of life that was
ordained on a Viera on iPod stoya
pistoia honest honest astoria story tell
Borg ooh Arab Sookie Allah honest oh
Jesus Jesus who he worshiped stay on Abu
Jaffa hope I'm doing that right now he
is the one Creator who gave us this
greeting of peace we're wishing upon you
now what's this all this for the people
who don't understand what I'm saying now
we're doing a specific show for those
from the Balkans who've drifted away
from the right way so we're going to be
trying to reach out out of the love to
our brothers from the Balkans and our
sisters from the Balkans and everyone
from all over the world can benefit
inshallah aquebogue now from this show
will be right back with my brother and
your brother from albania from New
Jersey Amash pendine here on the Dean
show this is 13 the teen jou
no this is the teacher this is the thing
is the theme this is the assalamualaikum
waalaikumsalam warahmatullah Monocacy
amar spending alhamdulillah Dorothy kako
SI al hamdulillah double estas mami
sophocleous managed directly you are
obscure nice for me era para una
nachtmahr veg tomato and veggie I'll
indeed service top of a snake east
mashallah pas le of I hahaha so I was
born in New York you came over from
albania at the age of what one but one
years old you still speak Albanian I do
it I still speak some broken Bosnian we
want to reach out to the people from the
Balkans all over the world people can
benefit doesn't even matter if you're
Serbian or Croatian or you're not a
Muslim yet these are nationalities
aren't they incorrect can a Serbian or a
creation they can submit to the will of
God and be a Muslim absolutely it's true
absolutely so you had this you have this
event coming up and I thought we'd make
a show that would try to help people
from that neck of the woods the Balkan
area who've drifted off they've kind of
you know taken certain cultures that
aren't really Islamic and we're trying
to out of the low because many have the
love they fought through communism and
they still held on to the belief in one
God but now you know we want to reach
out to have them come all the way back
this is your idea talk to us about this
idea you had well absolutely not
absolutely in the sense of it being my
idea but the love that we have for our
people and the sense of wanting to
really help them to see that what we are
practicing and teaching abyss
that it is no different than what the
Prophet himself peace be upon him has
actually called and taught the people
during his lifetime we have love for our
people in the same way that we have love
for all people we want what's good for
them naturally when you're of a certain
background he can't help but feel a bit
closer to the people because of the
ethnic ties and national ties and things
of that sort so this is a bit of that
expression in manifestation of love of
true compassion and concern for them of
hopefully being able to help them see
the beauty of Islam in chama now ms
Nahmad a muslima on estoy perdido Allahu
strappado Bhogle ok so what I just said
well we know that a Muslim is one who
has submitted not to Jesus or Mohammed
the son of the moon but the one who
created the Sun the Moon or near choice
or near Jenna on your next video Troy is
Jenna am I saying that right so now
we've defined this word Muslim how do
you define it in Albanian for the
Albanians out there they're like what's
this they're Muslim maybe or they're
considering being Muslim or they around
most somebody like they think Muslim is
an Arab thing how would you define in in
in the Albanian language what a Muslim
is what Islam is go ahead talk to him
well every sheep assuming net and fee on
Muslim on at I used nidhi you see all
the sword rogan olivet see don't here to
where Simba's ligeti a lot the believer
or the Muslim we used the same terminal
bein in Muslim is the one who basically
wants to submit and live according to
what Allah has given of teachings so
absolutely new coaster ever swim suit
chatter vistana suit Allah Isaac are you
chilled in a token and son in the
creation may yet o-neck Nazi may Allah
hounsou bahana adam f a million at the
mcrib near zine at the mcrib bottom to
understand that as a muslim it is to
live a life of happiness with God with
Allah who has division
also within oneself with one's family
with the larger family of humanity as
well as everything else of what Allah
has created to find your place within
the creation as a whole to be a Muslim
in the same way that everything else has
surrendered to live according to what
Allah has given of teachings so you can
still remain a Serb or a Croatian or any
other nationality right but do you have
to abandon that to be a Muslim see
that's one of the interesting points
that you bring I remember hearing as I
was growing up that shift our yeah and
they see each other job like you're
Albanian and you can't be anything else
you know Allah has created us whatever
our backgrounds are and we are naturally
supposed to be grateful to everything
for everything that Allah has given us
yo Mick zuman l-hamdu lillahi I'm
Cowboys shipped our sakamichi don't do
it may file and drew a la una parada
right in the same way that Allah has
also created you of a body in background
and someone else of an Arab or Turkish
or whatever the case may be whatever
Allah has decreed for us we welcome it
we are thankful and appreciative to
Allah for it but that's nationality
that's ethnicity and heritage and
there's no contradiction between that
and what religion itself is there's no
contradiction or is their competition
each one has its own place has its own
role in significance in the life of the
person mashallah tell us that we're
going to go to break now tell us this
was actually I was sitting with one of
your colleagues you actually finished
from the prestigious Medina University
you speak it also Arabic fluently you
graduated from that University was at
the same time around Yassa bridge as
actually he's my senior by about 45
years he spent some time in Bosnia doing
humanitarian aid helping the Africa
after the war I believe and he was also
having this this idea that we should
reach out to the people from the Balkans
because they've drifted away from the
way of all the prophets and messengers
and they've cited decided many of them
you know unconsciously consciously you
know to follow certain traditions that
are not
opposite to Islam you know so it's very
important that we're doing this episode
so inshallah God willing not to to judge
or be you know putting people down but
just trying to critique the situation so
we can like a doctor diagnose the
problem and God will and give some good
advice I mean yeah so what we're going
to we're going to take a break have you
talked to so have you had before going
to break have you had contact with shaky
ozamataz actually there was a phone call
about maybe a month or so back yeah you
know he speaks also buzzing he does yeah
it's bad how about Albanian no Albania
but his Bosnian is michela very good my
father's told me okay look we're going
to be right back to aquebogue da here on
the D show inshallah with more you think
these things are going to bring you
happiness you know why you keep going
back to the club and you keep going back
to these desires because you never find
satisfaction it's going to end up
causing you if it hasn't already a lot
of pain think you're happy you're
kidding yourself is really all what we
are offering in Islam what we have found
in Islam for ourselves is a means by
which our hearts aren't peace they're at
rest they're not discontent we are
pleased with what we have
gah
those who do good i am not afraid to
stay alone i am not afraid to stand
alone if a las vacas I i am not afraid
to stay alone i am not afraid to stand
alone if allies by my side i am not
afraid to stand alone i am not afraid to
stand alone if allies by my side i am
not afraid to stay
you
back here on the Dean show follows
toaster nah mostly older Nadine show and
again forgive me for my broken Bosnian
we want to really capture the attention
of those people from the Balkans our
brothers and sisters who are out there
now I'm gonna give you a story the other
day I was at the post office and I saw a
brother from what's called son Jack all
right you know her son jack is she older
gentleman he was walking with a cane
very nice suit dressed real nice he's
about in his 80s so I called over to him
and we started talking and I thought
it's a good opportunity because the
person really from talking to him way
before in the past that he wasn't
implementing Islam so I reminded him
about the Creator about a law and how
this show his life look how its past
your 85 years old now and all these good
times are gone now you should go ahead
and make hudge and just spend the rest
of your life really Institute you know
for all the mistakes that we've made and
he and and and this is a common argument
you could take off with this he said
what many say he said oh you know what
you know my great grandfather my father
used to pray or some family member
parade and they went to Hajj five times
and I'm like what about you why were
they better than you have you heard this
argument absolutely yeah yeah it's very
common to find that from our people
because understand that was for about
400 years part of the Ottoman Empire and
so Islam is something that has really
dug deep roots among our people and so
for over 400 years it was typical for
our people by Albanian Bosnian the
mixture of different peoples that are in
the Balkan areas to be at hamdulillah
very good devout Muslims to pray too
fast to address Islamic Lee to make the
hedge to give the zakat uphold the
pillars of Islam for example among other
things and so it was only unfortunately
with the communist regime basically
taking over would then became former
Yugoslavia that changed things but it's
typical to find and it was something
that's even interesting I remember
speaking with my father once before
where he said the first time he came to
me
dina while i was still a student there
when my first daughter was born and he
saw my wife with the niqab and he said i
remember seeing my mother dress like
this and i'm saying my grandma he goes
yeah your mother my mother your grandma
she used to wear the niqab prior to the
actual government passing a law saying
that women have to uncover their faces
and so it was this gradual breaking down
of the Islamic identity among our people
but they know very well because you're
still talking what about 20-30 part of
you 30 40 years of communist rule in
that sense perhaps even a little bit
more but you're talking a few
generations they know they've seen their
grandparents they've themselves prayed
they themselves faster they themselves
dressed Islamically but yet the kids or
the grandkids have it so they identify
with it and they see it but still
there's that barrier that's preventing
them from actually taking that step to
say hey you know what I'm the son of
so-and-so the daughter of so-and-so
hamdulillah they were Imams they were
shakes they were righteous people and I
can be just like him there's nothing to
prevent me or nothing that should
prevent me from doing so that's the key
I want to be like them because they were
upon that way that was pleasing to the
crater you know praying five times a day
giving in charity avoiding alcohol
avoiding gambling all the things that
the last and final messenger had warned
us about through the verbatim word of
God the Quran and reading the Quran and
not just having it up there during
Ramadan you it's collecting dust you
kiss it you put it on the shelf and
we've abandoned this this this guidance
from the crater and now we're just
Muslim by by name right is Muslim just
about being Muslim by name or is it by
action and in the same way that if you
were to ask an Albanian and this is
because my Albanian is not the best
either something I've learned from just
speaking home with my parents but could
fully sheep disappear tarvis eh off into
look Felicia made xishan you know like
when I speak Albanian it's kind of like
the village
you know Albanian and some of those were
well educated they listen they laugh now
some of them may even get to the point
where they may say and this was
something that happened laws the student
Medina they didn't call me out BTW they
would say American why because my
opinion was so poor so if imagine now
culturally speaking if you don't speak
the language you're not considered
Albanian you're not considered a Bosnian
what about being a Muslim how is it
possible that we would accept it
disabled you cannot do anything of what
islam teaches nothing of what Islam has
a has a beautiful teachings to and yet
to still say that it's okay in that I
must admit that there is no problem with
it when we don't accept that even at the
cultural level know what I mean yes
absolutely so this is you know I just
want to make this clear that we're going
to bring up some things that are
practiced and some things that we're
going to critique not in judging the
individual and putting them down it's in
a hope that we don't want them on the
day of judgment to be judged by Allah
and to end up in a place where it's very
hot and that's the Hellfire we want
everybody to be in Gemma in paradise so
talk is cheap and that's why Allah the
Creator he sent messengers to guide
mankind so we have to obey the last and
final messenger his way his sunnah and
we have to implement islam by our
actions by our speech by everything that
the Creator has told us to do not just
by talk talk is cheap so tell us some
common things is now you start
implementing Islam ok and for instance
the woman she wants to start to you know
put on the hijab ok she wants to cover
up dress modestly but the parents who
are Muslim they start chasing her out of
the house they start giving her a hard
time they start rebelling against her
and basically boycotting her I mean is
this and and and these are Muslims from
I mean probably most cultures might do
this but particular we see this it you
see an Albanian culture we see this in
the Bosnian culture it happens what
advice do you have for the 44 you know
the Bosnian parents now who are
listening or Albania and there right now
possibly having a conflict because their
daughter wants to dress with the fashion
that the crater sent down
not with the culture around miniskirts
and you know all this other stuff and
and that's it if parents were to
recognize that look we have still values
and traditions that for the most part
are good ones when it comes to Islam it
only further beautifies those values and
traditions so there should be no parent
that gets upset because their daughter
wants to cover herself and not to
uncover herself rather as parents you
should be proud you should be thankful
that she's not dressing in ways that are
going to cause her to become the perhaps
the meal of somebody sexual appetites
you should be happy and pleased to see
that she's a person who respects herself
visit my charge card see dude Sixtus way
yo T at the math on rich Buccola Tosh
often years at patata to own and the
rivington team Danny that she's making a
statement when she's dressing like that
she's saying I respect myself that I'm
more than just a physical body that you
know men can indulge in you know the
same thing with regards to even the
brothers will hamdulillah if they start
to practice and they start to grow a
beard and I remember that that was one
of the issues I had when I first started
just because the person grows a beard is
not that they've become an Arab or
something else yeah I remember seeing
pictures of people that are Imams from
the Albanians from the Bosnians from
over 50 years ago and more where they
had beards as big as this and bigger you
know what I mean there were things that
even tradition why is that with regards
to the clothing and I brought a little
token can I can I get a shitty so if you
know our out our people they would dress
in I had the coffee the American or
arabic style one but this here is an
Albanian one and because you know
Albanians and Bosnians our people got
some swagger they would have this stuff
hanging a bit to the side you know a
little bit up to the front like this and
it was like this is how they walked
around and they had no problem knowing
that in the Balkan area or even in
Europe when they went that this
identified them as not just being
Albanian and Bosnian but being
you know that means so they didn't have
problems with that this inferiority
complex that unfortunately has made some
of our people and not all at hamdulillah
but some of them think that if their son
or daughter were to dress islamically
where to start praying where to start
living the correct islamic life as if
they have something to fear as if
something's going to happen to them
nothing's going to happen if anything
it's only going to be good that's going
to happen for them for the children for
the family as a whole and there's many a
people let's proof for this now we'll
see parents pushing pushing hard for the
children to study to study so they can
graduate you know get that masters that
PhD that GED whatever it is but now the
formula the blueprint of the crater sent
down that improves your character that
helps you to be the best among society
that helps you to be a better son a
better father it's a complete way of
life Islam when you submit to the crater
it produces good results only good
results this is right a hundred percent
so now they're said oh when you start
practicing you start praying to the
crater the one guy the same God Jesus
worship Mohammed worship Abraham you
don't worship His creation but the one
create tour you're doing Islam
submitting to the will of God like slow
down man you're going too much you know
they're promoting you're going too fast
now you got you know till 5060 a Justi
Pusha you know to just slow it down why
do you think this is what is it they're
discouraging the youth and they'd rather
see their daughters out there dating in
the nightclub in the places that boys
and girls are mixing alcohol and next
thing you know you got all sorts of evil
that's coming from this but now they
want to do good and even the parents are
preventing them from doing good what
advice do we have will tell the parents
yavash yavash slow down to the parents
because what they are really doing is
they they're allowing Shaitaan to take
advantage of their ignorance if you can
understand that as parents in the way
that you love your kids and you want
only what's best for them Allah he loves
us even more than we can love our
children he cares for us even more than
we can care for our children the
teachings that Allah gives us
they are for the betterment of our lives
as well as our family and parents lives
so parents need to understand that when
a child their child is going to practice
Islam they should not all of a sudden
start discouraging it but rather they
should realize that look this is only
going to make my child more respectful
towards me this is going to make my
child only a more decent person that
with regards to what they may have and
unfortunately among our people we have
problems of alcoholism of gambling of
all sorts of other different problems to
see that inshallah the son of mine who
will hamdulillah is praying that he's
not gonna drink that he's not going to
gamble that he's not going to be some
loser who's going to you no harm his
family but rather he's going to be in
sha Allah this great person that is
going to be a role model in the family
that he's going to be all these other
wonderful things in the girl just the
same she's not gonna bring any shame to
herself to her family she is not going
to in any way destroy her life in her
future she is not going to do these
different things that our grandparents
themselves never did and so it's not
about us leaving and changing and doing
something bad we're actually going back
to what our roots are that's the the
ruse that we're trying to go back to
we'll be right back with more here on
the Dean show inshallah the D everything
the this cup is insincere submission to
the one who triggered it because it's
following the rules of gravity by
definition this is how we can say that
Islam has been here since the very
beginning of time anywhere the Muslims
went to people embrace Islam in massive
countries nations and this is something
that is amazing never happened on the
face of earth when people saw a
practical way of life of being truthful
honest making sense of everything that
they do they worship they buy in
if allies by my side I am not afraid to
stand alone I am NOT a saint you stand
alone if allies by my side I am not
afraid to stay alone I am not afraid to
stand alone if Eliza I am not afraid to
stand
back here on the Dean show and we're
reaching out to the viewing audience
from the balcony area and we're trying
to give them some heart softeners
they're going to soften their hearts out
of the love because their judgment is
closed and this message is lucid it's
clear worship one create tour jesus
never claimed he was God yo-yos echoecho
diode book yo-yos echoecho deseo noble
java knee anika deal jesus never said he
was God did he not clearly no never and
we don't worship Jesus do we we worship
the one who created Jesus and that's
aslam submitting to the creator and
doing all the good that he's told us to
do so even for those people who are not
yet Muslim they can say hey that makes
sense I never believed this whole
Trinity thing anyway I just want to
worship one God so that's the message of
Islam and doing the action so we kind of
expounded on some of these things we
have to do another episode to go further
into it superstitions you know people
abandoning the Hajj until they're like
60 you know the banian mafia guy now
he's you know making this whole thing
into it to a click to a gang you know
you've seen these two in New York is big
i heard albania albania na mobsters and
now so someone's to talk about man and
overall general advice we're coming to a
close you know superstitious such a
thing in Islam no the reading the coffee
cups and then you know you go to night
club and now you're feeling guilty
you're missing something so you go to
the Imam I'm supposed to be an example
but he's charging you 200 100 bucks
these maybe was called the Himalaya
putting it around your neck kiss it or
you got the big law chain and now this
is like your badge right but you're in a
nightclub drinking and you're a mafia
guy are these things also in Albanian
culture you have there what do we got to
say I think that with regards to these
things as you mentioned I think in the
next session we'll need to really talk
about some of these things in a bit more
detail the main focus of what you did
mention is that we do not worship except
for one God say that in Albanian look
bathroom veg tan dessert some arborio
rice totally honest territorial zone
that's it yeah Danny ouch yeah that
pitch one yeah not three and one
just one that's simple the same God that
Jesus himself worshiped the same God
that Muhammad worship the same God that
mousse on Ibrahim Moses and Ibrahim in
all of the more [ __ ] my loss peace and
blessings be upon them so Islam is
nothing more than the continuation of
what every prophet came to teach believe
in the one God worship only this God
live life in the way that God has given
and you're going to have the happiest
life in this world you'll be saved from
punishment than hell in the next and in
addition to that you'll be entered into
the gardens of bliss for eternity and
you don't have to be paying for those
Amalia throw that stuff that stuff has
nothing to do with Islam these
superstitions no they don't mean no no
no no no no okay so we got a lot more
Tubba you're actually going to be
talking about this you got an invent for
people who are in the area they want to
maybe fly into the event there from the
Balkan area even if they're you know
whoever they are they can come in to
your much did the 25th is it yep made
25th Friday May twenty-fifth and we have
a feel to the side of our building so if
anybody wants the heliport in they can
do that too hola but it'll be in sha
Allah it's a free event we're gonna have
dinner as well as in sha Allah something
of a nice presentation some Bosnian
Albanian for our brothers and sisters in
child this is at the the Muslim
community center in rockford and
Rockford you guys have a website we do
the website may still be down though but
the address is 5921 Darlene drive
Rockford Illinois 6 11 09 and we hope to
see is in Charlotte okay so before we
cut out you know gifts are always
encouraged and we're going to give you a
gift inshallah right now we have the the
nua you see purpose of life let's get a
zoom in on this and hope you're a size
large so you know this is a gift for you
and we encourage our are viewing daily
follow follow follow my straw go here
you go here we go and we also have the
purpose of light bumper stickers we have
a brother Mohammad Khan who helped put
these together may Allah reward him and
we encourage people they can pick this
up as a gift eat for you allocate I sure
will you did thank you very much mellow
bless you too and we also before we cut
out now and last but not least people
have been waiting they've been waiting
you know for
years people want to know my story and I
was really reluctant I really didn't
want to talk about the past but you know
from talking with people more knowledge
and you know really reflecting making us
to hodda praying I thought you know
people like this could be of benefit so
we kind of didn't go into the details we
kind of made a film so we had two hooked
up with a filmmaker who made the film
dunya to Dean it's finally here you saw
the film and you know it has the new
volume form of the Dean show so you've
seen it we actually have what are your
comments cuz you've seen the film we've
you know we've had other people comment
on it you recommended that this be shown
in different discussion groups and
Islamic centers mustards woody was your
comment on the Dean show dunya to Dean
for those who haven't seen it I'll
reiterate what I have said in the past I
think it's a wonderful story that
touches on many of the true things of
challenges that a youngster growing up
in this country will also face where
they want to have money they want to
have friends they want to have the girls
they want to have the party life they
want to have all of these things that
they perceive are going to give them
happiness and make them feel significant
and important in the way that you
yourself had but then to realize that
look you know what you get it it's not
what it was meant to be it's not all
that it was made out to be so to see how
a person like yourself who had it and
then walks away from it realizing that
it does nothing to feed the heart to
feed the soul it does nothing to really
add to the significance of who you are
and to see that what does make that
change a difference is Islam I think
that it's a it's a transformational
experience and movie that you put
together there so I really recommend
that it's something that should be seen
something that our youth should also be
brought into a discussion about just so
that we can learn from history not be
doomed to repeat it absolutely
absolutely that's why we made the Dean's
show so it could be a benefit to mankind
help people after watching it who aren't
Muslim thinking about me muslim thinking
about the purpose of like to really
reflect if they're not reflecting
watching the film God willing
be a tool that people can use to help
people really reflect upon the
seriousness of figuring out the purpose
of light before def over text us you get
the Dean show then you're to Dean volume
4 thank you very much thank you for
being with us we're going to have to do
another program for the people in the
Balkan area soon inshallah acabo de
finding min daily show look forward to
it thank you some weight walaikum Salam
and thank you for tuning in to another
episode of the Dean show share this
episode with all your friends or your
family and those who've been away from
the Creator they've been found their
lusts and their desires and their
passions know that this life will end
this life will end and we will be judged
on the day of judgment and there's a
hellfire and there's a paradise and we
want to strive to love our Creator the
way that he has communicated to us do
all his messengers Muhammad peace be
upon him being the last and final
messenger and we have the verbatim word
of God the Quran and the Sunnah the
authentic sayings of the last final
messenger get to know this Quran read
the Quran connect connect with the Quran
connect with your crater so you can
achieve great success in this life and
the next and we'll look forward to see
you next time here on the Dean show
aquebogue inshallah don't forget to
visit Eddie DVD com to pick up dunya to
Dean we'll see you next time peace be
unto you